how's it going reject nation Greg John
we're gonna watch today from how it
should have ended Justice League how
Justice League should have ended with
the Snyder cut
oh right from then it would it would
have been good right would have been
perfect
I like Justice League some people don't
[Music]
but he got they bumper man a game here
only did you do things look masculine
[Music]
okay so I'm gonna look masculine maybe
you need I'm actually already part of
another team
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
okay here we go
Schneider cut he'll protect the mother
box on what about Superman is fine as a
Jerry
I'm so happy for them so how did you
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
like our thing any more thing we do well
we finally did it
we finally showed the world bazaar your
facial hair is just too distracting if
we could just there we go
saying we finally showed the world that
real heroes do exist now the world can
be inspired again because we are great
role models not even close
yeah I think we sort of rushed a team
here estimate the seriously divided its
Superman origin nope because I'm a
beacon of hope and inspiration
when did you say inspiring things
exactly let's maybe the eighties
[Music]
if you refuse to world build then you do
deserve a world at all yes we'd Martha
it's six versus one make that seven to
the party Steve sounds amazing
can I call you Steve as you wish
oh my gosh I'm so over this Martha thing
Justice League huddle flash you take
damage
Martha's ankles cyborg you grab his arms
oh my gosh have we learned nothing
yeah you better not be wasting my time
we have to level the playing field mr.
[ __ ] to put it plainly
should we have a meeting tomorrow
actually we already have that what the
where did you come from
[Music]
you just wanted you to know it exists
just how it should have ended is that
and again they made a funny video with
some actual points you know all those
times they killed Steppenwolf in this
video it was thinking oh yeah you know
he did have his face exposed his neck
vulnerable there were times where you
you could have just stabbed his flesh
and it would have taken care of the job
and had never thought about that perhaps
the one that makes the most sense to me
is the flash one when bends like take
the sword right there that makes no
sense with the funniest ones I mean the
Warriors a bit mascara
artha bit they need a tease for a long
time ago I forgot what video was it I
remember seeing this - yeah it's nice to
know they they wrapped up that storyline
but on you for doing the serial thing I
thought that was their interpretation of
Adam warlock and maybe it still is I
just like this how it should have ended
was like fully off in its own universe
funny about it is normally the house you
have edit is just the series of clips of
the actual movie but then there's
community to their own storyline here
the longest bit was dedicated to how how
how should have ended would have ended
in there all the different like you know
argue it's back and forth about who's
cut which movie like oddly that fit for
me somebody else is back here and that
whole thing at the beginning to or they
like
Honan mouth Superman's mouth yeah with
the kid in the phone my favorite one
without a moustache you were but how'll
shows up for a green lantern with a
Wonder Woman yeah sir falling in love
with eg I don't me Steve it seems like
they understand the characters pretty
well him they could have done their own
Justice League movie actually hey man I
think everybody should get a chance to
do a cut of their own justice just kind
of making fun of the fact of how Aquaman
is so kind of in essential to the group
in the movie yeah I'd like to the flash
keeps stealing has tried to get stuff
done and then they completely repeat the
dialogue from anchorman for like a few
minutes yeah just appreciated the
Superman bit where they're talking about
like no you're you're a symbol of hope
right yeah when did you ever say
anything I said something I thought
about like throughout the lot of Justice
League and I like how they touched on
Flash's time travel a bit how'd you know
though this is the key I think that was
something that I did think was missing
from Justice League was acknowledging
the time travel a bit from BBS yeah and
his longer hair and beard yeah but he
does that beyond that I think the Thai
travel bit was something that should
have been acknowledged in some capacity
yeah Justice League I wonder it's
eyebrows gonna be in the Teen Titans
show that's gonna come out which I hear
is gonna be awesome I met a couple
people who have been working on it can't
reveal anything I've heard about it from
what I've heard it's gonna be it's gonna
be different and I'm excited for it yeah
yeah yeah I mean like now that we've had
like a gigantic intro why not why not
yeah let's get to know that character as
a young man thanks for watching Thank
You Izzy for doing this you can
subscribe to the reject nation click
that notification about the subscription
buttons mean something we'll catch you
later